the same thoughts that keep you up at
night keep me up at night because for a
long time for me
money was a motivator because i grew up
poor so i know what it's like to not
have anything and then to have money
you're like oh is this it my motivator
is creating as long as i'm alive i'm
just going to have ideas and i'm going
to try and make them happen that is
where i've now become comfortable within
myself and in all of those ideas if i
can give back and make someone feel good
or make them laugh or or provide
something that changes their life in a
little way then i'm happy hey friends
welcome back to deep dive if you're new
here my name is ali and in each episode
i chat to entrepreneurs authors creators
and other inspiring people about how
they got to where they are and the
strategies and tools that we can
collectively use on our shared journey
of living healthier happier more
productive lives my conversation this
week is with patricia bright patricia is
a youtuber an entrepreneur a writer a
podcaster and so many more things she's
got 2.85 million subscribers on her
fashion and beauty channel she has
another half a million subscribers on a
personal finance theme channel and she's
got over one million followers on her
instagram where she posts mostly about
beauty and lifestyle and that kind of
stuff but her life wasn't always like
this uh her journey started in a council
estate in south london where to use her
words she was totally broke and when she
was in school she became this
self-proclaimed hustler she started
making money uh doing hair for the girls
in her school for five pounds of pop so
that she could make money to buy school
dinners with and from those humble
beginnings she is now ceo of a
multi-million dollar empire in this
episode we touch on a few things we talk
about success the idea of success where
that comes from from how kind of
financial success relates to success in
life and how me and patricia think about
those things we talk about how we can
figure out what to do with our career in
terms of like do we want to do something
that makes a lot of money or do we want
to do something that follows our passion
and that we feel more fulfilled by i
really enjoyed having the conversation
um it's amazing how open and transparent
and honest patricia is and how much of
herself she has kind of put out there on
the internet so without further ado i
hope you enjoyed this conversation
between me and patricia bright you
started your youtube channel in 2010
like agent like in the original original
days of youtube and
um obviously the the um the landscape of
youtube was very different in 2010 than
it is now in 2022. very different um and
you've become like phenomenally
successful on the platform you've got
your own like youtube original series
you've got your own documentary you had
the podcast which did amazingly
billboards and times square that that
whole shebang um
one thing that you said in in your in
your youtube original documentary thing
was that you've had all the success but
you don't feel successful
and i wanted to ask like what what what
do you mean by that so i actually think
that was at the time then i've had a lot
of um therapy and coaching since then
and i'm really excited by what i've done
but at the time naturally i'm not very
good at seeing the things that i've
achieved because there's so many things
that i still want to do and i think what
is the definition of success is like
quite hard to
to put your finger on and i don't think
at the time i had my finger on what
success looked like to me and i felt
like there was more things that i wanted
to do and there still are there are more
things that i want to do so that's maybe
one of the reasons why i felt like i
wasn't successful but i take it back
because i am successful and i've done
amazing so yeah what was the
what were the learnings from say therapy
or coaching and stuff that made you
now feel that oh i'm actually successful
oh just mindset like i didn't realize
that you know thoughts become and i'll
shout out to jacqueline because she's
amazing and she's helped me a lot um but
thoughts become your feelings right so i
realized that i had the wrong kind of
thoughts these weird imposing thoughts
that would say you're not successful or
you haven't done or you haven't achieved
so then i would feel like that whereas
now if i look at the reality of actually
i've done this thing i've got a show
i've had a youtube channel for 10 years
i've built an audience i
have sold product i've done so many
things actually all that evidence
supports um success in the things i've
wanted to be successful in so
that is that's it okay just looking at
the reality so it's so it sounds like
you're sort of objectively analyzing be
like here here are all my kind of
accolades achievements etc
therefore surely this must be me and i'm
successful and then if you tell yourself
that enough then over time uh with the
right professional to help you help
guide you through the process you
genuinely start to believe it yeah you
just look at the facts like and i think
sometimes our minds tell us
all these weird lies that aren't
actually based in like reality it's not
true so you have to sometimes take a
step out and look at it from a more
logical perspective and then replace
those weird
biological or weird psychological
thoughts to then um
kind of reframe things
it strikes me that like so you are the
sort of by almost every definition
phenomenally successful um
do you think that let's say
if there is a more normal person
listening to this who doesn't have like
huge businesses and brands built up
under their name
um
do you need to have those kind of
essentially tick boxes in order to feel
successful or do you think there's stuff
that people who
aren't as objectively successful as you
can do or can think to
essentially feel feel better about
themselves uh that kind of thing
definitely well i think it's for you to
define what success means for you so
what does that look like success might
be i got that job that i wanted to apply
for or i got the grade or i did the work
i needed to do so i'm successful or i've
looked after my family well so i think
that the first place
everyone needs to start is defining
what's important to them and why those
factors are important to them is it from
external sources or peer pressure or
social media are all of those things
being told to you that they're important
or are they coming from yourself so
that's a whole exercise everybody needs
to do like what do i actually want who
do i actually want to be what do i
actually find
what do i define success as to me
and then check yourself why do i think
that makes me successful
is it external factors so without the
kind of exercises that you did with your
coach and
therapists and things or yeah yes yes in
terms of thinking about stuff a lot more
but i think i've just become a more
introspective person in general
and i just like to analyze like why do i
think and feel or want a certain thing
especially because i'm in this world i
know what that pressure of seeing
what everybody else is doing seeing what
everyone else has like i can see how
that can completely com bombard your
brain and tell you you need that you
need to be like that and then sometimes
you just have to check yourself so i've
had to do a lot of checking of myself
over and over again um to really be
clear on what makes me tick
yeah this is the stuff that i've been
thinking about a lot recently like in
the last year or so especially like
after i left medicine and decided that
hey i'm going to go all in on this like
internet stuff
it was a case of like defining well what
is this internet stuff um
do i still working that out yeah exactly
like what does what does the brand look
like what do i actually want to be doing
three years five years from now in a
world that's constantly evolving
and like i can't imagine myself
continuing to be like hey friends
welcome back to the channel when i'm 50
years old so what the hell am i gonna be
doing then like how how did you kind of
tackle these these sorts of thoughts so
i'm still tackling those thoughts but
the way i tackle it is that i've i've
just find that for me i like the idea of
being able to think about something
that i'm interested in and making that
thing become something so that is my
process so if it's a case of i want to
grow tomatoes tomatoes tomatoes um and i
and i work out how to get my soil the
right ph and i find the seeds and i
water them every day and i grow tomatoes
then i'm happy so it as long as i'm able
to kind of
make decisions and we're all going to
make different decisions
at so many different phases in our lives
like maybe it's for me also parenting
was one for me so i knew that i wanted
to have children i'm gonna do it and i
did it
not that it's hard to do that but it's
kind of hard like nowadays but yeah that
is how i'm kind of going through the
process now it's just my desire just to
keep creating
and it might not be creating on youtube
it might be creating life it might be
creating a vegetable garden it might be
creating a brand but i can do that at
95. okay i can still create so i've
realized that's what i want to be as an
individual
okay so yeah often when i speak so when
i speak to people who are maybe in their
sort of early to may 20s and they're
having that crisis of i don't know what
to do
um you know a lot of the internet would
say hey fi find your passion and follow
that passion i don't believe in that oh
you don't believe in that don't believe
in passions i absolutely think that's so
dead yeah okay sorry i just interrupted
you but
i don't believe in like
the idea of following a passion
especially if you're broke or you're
hungry because passion may not put food
on the table and passion isn't gonna pay
the rent right so once you've been able
to kind of
deal with those basis those basics there
like get those covered and then i think
it's about you defining like
what is something you have skills in
doing now
and um
you again
are interested in you can execute in
that kind of those key areas and
i wouldn't call that passion i just call
it what i call it like working on your
strengths or
or like playing to your strengths that
kind of thing yeah playing to your
strengths but just doing something so
like sometimes that that you you're
waiting for passion to come or like a
wind of inspiration to come and it's not
going to come you're going to wait
forever so it's better to just do
something anything it doesn't even have
to be the thing that you're passionate
about or you like maybe it's a thing you
can do right there and then it might be
like
oh i'm not passionate okay let me just
you know read the book or clean my room
or make a meal or go on a walk doing
something versus doing nothing is a good
idea um
yeah it's kind of like what cal newport
talks about in so good they can't ignore
you uh he talks about this idea of
kind of follow follow your passion is
really terrible advice because as you
said you know you're i'm passionate
about playing the guitar the chances of
me making a career playing the guitar
are minuscule
and uh instead if you aim to become
really good at something then a passion
often develops for the thing that you
are then really good at i love that and
then you can as you become good at the
thing
it then gives you
career capital and often the thing that
makes people passionate about their job
is a sense of autonomy a sense of
freedom a sense that they can do what
they want with their time and if you're
really good at something you can then
negotiate autonomy even if you even if
you're not an entrepreneur or a creator
even as an employee you can
find that passion but you have to become
good at something first
rather than thinking oh i'm passionate
about guitar i'm passionate about
football i'm obviously going to make a
career out of that which is just kind of
generally unrealistic for most people
exactly i even say this that i'm
actually passionate about eating sweets
and chocolate and watching netflix but
that is not going to be helpful for me
in the long run if i just focus on
binging on shows and eating
high calorie snacks that aren't good for
me
we're going to take a very quick break
to introduce our sponsor for this
episode who is brilliant i've been using
brilliant for the last few years and
they're a fantastic interactive platform
with online courses in maths science and
computer science my personal favorites
are the computer science courses i think
are absolutely fantastic and when i was
initially applying to med school i was
actually torn between applying to
medicine and applying to computer
science and i ended up going with
medicine in the end which i really don't
regret but there's a big part of me that
really wanted to continue learning the
stuff around computer science continuing
to understand how coding works and the
courses on brilliant have given me that
foundation in computer science which i
didn't have before the courses are
really fun engaging and interactive and
the way they teach you stuff is based on
very first principles thinking like
they'll teach you a concept and then
they'll take you through interactive
exercises to actually help solidify your
understanding of that concept and it's
pretty cool because they're always
updating the library with new courses
for example there's one they've just
released called everyday maths which is
kind of like a visual exploration of the
maths that we use in everyday life like
for example fractions and percentages
and putting them in a context that makes
it very understandable and certainly
very different to the kind of boring way
that i was taught maths when i was in
school the courses and lessons are
particularly good if you have a busy
life with lots of stuff going on because
they really teach you the stuff in
bite-sized chunks so you can always
return to a course at a later date if
you don't have time to do it in one
sitting if any of that stands up your
street then do head over to
brilliant.org forward slash deep dive
and the first 200 people to hit that
link which is also going to be in the
video description and in the show notes
we'll get 20 off the annual premium
subscription so thank you so much to
brilliant for sponsoring this episode
how do you balance that out though like
sort of the
balance between i'm watching netflix
because i think it's really fun versus
um
i'm gonna hustle for my businesses
because kind of ladder i want to climb
i get a lot of guilt from doing
like sitting back and like watching
netflix and doing nothing so it's a
struggle for me
and then i then go on binges and i'm
like three hours deep into
a show yeah um so it's really hard to
navigate that but i think
fundamentally
i feel like there's so much i know that
i want to achieve that time wasted on
stuff like that just isn't worth my
energy um so i avoid
play a lot
but i enjoy what i'm doing so like i
work on a saturday and i have to stop
myself from working on a sunday because
i'm like but i'm enjoying this i like
this i want to create i want to think of
ideas this is my fun to me i'd rather do
this than just watch a show um but it's
not healthy probably to like work all
the time
yeah i think i i have the same thing as
well um
where
you know my housemate might be like oh
why are you working at 11 p.m on a
saturday i'm like right it doesn't feel
like work because it's just fun and i
would i genuinely get more pleasure out
of
i don't know coming up with video ideas
or
dabbling with some logo design for a new
product that i'm doing then i would out
of watching bridgette on netflix or
something
exactly um where do where do you think
that feeling of guilt comes from though
you said you feel guilty when you when
you do a little binge it's not an
external thing it's not that someone's
gonna make me feel bad about it it's
like an internal pressure that i've kind
of put on myself like i think we all
know when there's certain things we need
to get done like even if it's doing our
homework we know we need to get it done
and if we're not doing it we're gonna
feel a certain way so maybe it's just
something on the inside that knows that
you should be doing something better one
thing that i've been
i guess struggling with is is it's very
much a first world problem but it's um
like
once you've ticked the box of like
financial success yeah then in a way the
question in my mind becomes well
what's the point of trying to grow the
audience trying to launch more products
is it to make more money
is it to help people but like i can help
people without
selling my products like so why would i
sell my products you know
perhaps it is to make money like is it
fame is it like i don't know getting
more and more accolades is it to get on
forbes study on the third like
what what the hell am i doing all this
for um
yeah how do you think about it so the
same thoughts that keep you up at night
keep me up at night because the reality
is when money is no longer a motivator
because for a long time for me
money was a motivator because i grew up
poor so i know what it's like to not
have anything and then to have money
you're like oh is this it it's like oh
okay and then like i had an extra
central crisis and i was like oh my god
i don't care about money anymore um in
that way um so i think that
it's like the again i've just find my
motivator is creating as long as i'm
alive i'm just gonna have ideas and i'm
gonna try and make them happen that is
where i've now become comfortable within
myself um and in all of those ideas if i
can give back and make someone feel good
or make them laugh or or provide
something that changes their life in a
little way then i'm happy so i've
defined that for myself now okay it
sounds like your north star kind of your
core value almost is to always be
creating yeah do something yeah create
something and like you know that that
that process of idea to execution fills
you with a lot of like internal joy
that's it and even if you didn't make
any money from it you'd still be doing
this and you'd still want to do it when
you're 95 years old 100 yeah nice but
i've i've just defined that for myself
over
over the last like two years or so that
i realized that is the thing that drives
me that's what made me make videos i
just wanted to make something i was
bored so i had to create and then when i
created i was happy and then it became a
business and then i was doing the same
thing and i was bored of that form of
creation so i need to like switch it up
for myself yeah i think for me the this
sort of north star thing is
just uh
teaching basically like for me it's less
about creating and more about teaching
is that that's the thing that i would do
if i wasn't getting paid for it it's the
thing i imagined myself continuing to do
at the age of 95. perfect and i guess
um
i guess for someone listening to this
that's like something to ask yourself is
like what is what is the thing that you
would do if you won the euro millions
and you didn't need to worry about money
like exactly how would you actually
spend your time you probably wouldn't
spend it like sipping cocktails on a
beach in thailand for more than two
weeks that's kind of boring after a
while
um you'd probably spend it doing
something or other and there's this new
coach called corey who i've started
working with a couple weeks ago
and he coaches a bunch of executives and
things who have taken that box of have
made enough money
um and what he encourages them to do is
find this one core value and it's
generally rooted in some form of service
like
you know initially i thought my core
value was freedom
but
freedom is kind of like a networked good
in that it's only really useful if other
people that you hang out with also have
similar freedom otherwise yeah you're
watching netflix at nine in the morning
on a monday or your friends are at work
exactly it's that's just not not
inherently fun and so looking at it from
a service angle
made me realize that the thing that i
care about is the freedom to learn and
teach on my own terms yeah and now i see
that as like the north star and it's
like almost everything is optimizing
towards oh i mean you know is this
moving me towards freedom to learn and
teach on my own terms or away from it
and it's moving me away from it then
there needs to be a really really really
strong reason as to why i'm doing the
thing
perfect and it sounds like for you that
similar thing is creating in a way that
potentially helps other people exactly
exactly it's nice to like be clear on
that and i think it takes people a while
to define
what that is for them and yeah even
learning to kind of listen to your own
internal voice to determine what you
truly are about like i think most of us
are even scared to look inside to like
see
what do i actually like i actually don't
care about this kind of thing and it's
scary to you know shed off
the what's the things the
the expectations of the world and
outside and then just understanding
yourself more and then
being unapologetic in in that is like
scary but fun how would someone
how so how would you think about this
let's say if you were still broke if you
were still if you hadn't take that box
i've made enough money to be comfortable
how do you square that i need to make
money i need to pay the bills with
i want to do the thing that fills me
with joy i want to follow my north star
i wouldn't square it um okay no i've
been too broke to try and square it in
the middle okay that's why
and that's sad but that's how i am
there's
there's money to be made there's work to
be done like that's why so when i grew
up i um
wanted to do fashion um
fashion is a non sound so bad but at the
time it's a non-industry there is no
money in that and i was like oh that's
what i want to do i love clothes
and i realize there is no revenue in it
when i was at university i quickly
switched to accounting because
accounting is a steady and stable job
like and i got my job and i was secured
in it and i found enjoyment out of one
the learning in accounting i actually
chose accounting because there was a
module my fashion course that was
accounting and i was really good at it
and i was like oh i could do this this
is fun i love numbers so fundamentally i
i think it's difficult depending on
where you are with squaring
needing to make a living and
be
following your passion i just wouldn't
do it i would just make a living how i
need to
and then leave passions for the weekend
nice i think most people do that yeah
like
you can't have both all the time i don't
think um yeah i think it's a fairly
modern thing in the world of like uh
i've been doing a bunch of research into
sort of the
the history of work why and where that's
coming from you know as part of my book
we've got a bunch of books here that all
about like the history of work and just
this idea that it's it's a relatively
recent phenomenon this idea that the
thing that we do for work is also the
thing that should ideally fulfill us and
that's what passion and things and i
think in a dream world of course like
everyone wants to do a job that they are
also passionate about but in the real
world probably
it's quite quite hard to get to that
point and it sounds like you know having
having been broke it's way better to be
making money and having passions on the
weekend
than it is i guess to be following your
passion and not making money
would you say that's fair to say or i
mean i just think about people who have
to farm every day and people who worked
in the coal mines do you think they're
like i'm not passionate about this they
just got on with on with it and like i
think sometimes when you're doing a good
job at what you're doing eventually you
you enjoy it so even when i worked at i
worked at a really cool bank i worked at
bank of tokyo and um i just loved i love
spreadsheets anyway but i didn't know
that i love spreadsheets and other
people think it's a really boring thing
but like when i was in it and i was
really involved i was having a great
time like it wasn't my passion but i
felt
excited to be able to execute well in
what i was doing and my like manager
liked me and i was doing a good job so i
could have done that for many many years
and being comfortable really but
yeah there's a quote i came across the
other day uh which was along the lines
of you know throughout history
um
uh essentially whenever whenever you're
doing a craft and there is the
opportunity to do something well
doing that thing well is a profound
source of joy and meaning yes and
i find that for me and for friends that
i speak to
when we sort of half-ass our work for
the sake of i'm not really enjoying it
i'm gonna half-ass it so that i can go
home and play video games in the evening
or whatever
that feels a lot worse than thinking i
don't really enjoy my work but i'm just
gonna try getting really good at it and
even though you're putting in more work
it just energizes you to a far greater
degree than half-assing it and living
for the weekends as it were does exactly
100 agree with that and even someone
could say like being a youtuber is the
funnest job in the world or say someone
who plays video games for like a living
that might be the funnest job in the
world but i bet you there are times
where that play is like i just don't
want to do this today this is boring i'm
over it but if they do it well and play
well they'll be like okay i'm enjoying
this like i think fundamentally almost
all jobs in all careers can become
a bit tedious and it's about how you
focus on
how you channel your energy into it
which will change how you feel about it
let's talk about money it's about money
money seems to be one of your one of
your uh favorite favorite topics just
like it's one of mine yeah i like
talking about money yeah so you're
you're very open about money and stuff
um which is still even in 2022 a little
bit rogue
uh where does your yeah how
how do you feel about money probably
i like money i think it's a really good
tool i think it's really valuable
um i think it gives you loads of options
and i think
from not having money to then having it
like i can just see the benefits of how
it makes life so much easier okay like
what's that before and after like
like
the choices that you have to make
you can probably take a bit more time to
make a choice when you
you have more money you can be a bit
more patient about taking the next step
was if you are desperate for
where your next paycheck is going to
come from you may take
a shortcut or you may do something that
isn't the best for you because you
really need that income which is what so
many people are dealing with all the
time so i think that money gives you the
freedom
to make choices that are more thought
out and potentially better in the long
term for you yeah
um so you've got this
uh extra this sort of second youtube
channel the break which is going on
website and products and things like
that where you educate people about kind
of money and finances and stuff i will
put links to all of that stuff wherever
people are watching or listening to this
um
how
how much do you think it's actually
possible for people to i guess
change their lot in life kind of the
whole racks to riches thing is that
like how how does that happen and is is
that actually achievable for normal
people do you think
like what what are the different factors
that go on here this is uh really hard
and also quite an upsetting question
because i actually really don't think
most people are going to go from rags to
riches i feel like it's a 0.001
i feel like it's based in a lot of luck
i think um it's based in so many
different factors that most people are
not going to be able to ever control
like if you grow up
in
some village and
or a desert that's that's it you've been
born into that no amount of work hard is
going to
make the rain come out of the sky to
fulfill the drought that is causing your
animals to die like that's something
that you cannot control so i think
there's a lot of factors that people
can't control but i do think that people
can focus on the little things that they
can control um to make their life a
little bit easier but most people aren't
going to go from rags to witches they
might just have minor incremental
improvements in their lifetime and so
when you advise people or like it's not
technical financial advice but when you
educate people about money
what are the
like i guess i guess if you were
speaking to your younger self when you
were broke
what what is the advice you would have
given to that younger younger person
actually my number one advice is don't
do what everybody else is doing
like
we're really under pressure to like
spend and have and do
and
fit in and i would just advise myself
don't do that because most of that stuff
isn't helpful for most people the
classics make sense
save
where you can as much as you can
and make more
where you can how you can
and live a bit more frugally if you're
struggling financially and then invest
in yourself and invest in other things
to aid your opportunities for long-term
growth so i i believe in those
principles and that's what i would
advise anybody and everyone i'm not
saying it's going to make you rich it's
not going to make you a millionaire it's
not going to make you a billionaire but
it might make your life a little bit
easier if you develop those basics
around finances
what are the kind of biggest mistakes
that you see people slash that you made
when you were younger um
in the realm of in the realm of money to
be honest i was pretty good with money
um because again i say this all the time
when you don't have like you don't i
don't want to spend money um i'm
wittening but on
on crazily because i didn't have it to
spend like that so i was pretty smart
with my money and i was really good at
making money so i was making money from
bit from 11 years old in terms of i knew
that i liked money and i knew that i
wanted it and i knew that if my parents
can't give me dinner money to go to
school then i'm gonna make my own dinner
money so i would um like do hair in the
playground and i'd make five pounds here
and then i would make products and i'd
sell products and you know even at uni i
had a part-time job and then i would
have my own clients as well so i would
do hair so i would always have money but
i would always try and save it and then
spend it on the things that you know i
liked and
um
were valuable to me but i never spent
all of my money and i'd never be
entirely broke but then say my biggest
money mistakes came
when i actually started making more
money and it was around like the whole
business side of money i didn't know
that i had to pay taxes oh and i was an
accountant yeah
and i worked in banking so i obviously
had a full-time job and then i bought a
house when i was 23 me and my husband we
bought a house together which was really
good at the time and i was making money
and i was just spending the money that i
made you know on the house or and things
that i wanted and then i didn't realize
that i was meant to pay my um
corporation tax i didn't even know what
corporation tax was and then i ended up
being slapped with a fine for like 15
000 pounds and at the time i was like
where the hell am i gonna get 15 000
pounds from i don't i don't know what
that means i didn't know how to like
manage that or anything so that was the
like one of the big mistakes i made oh
well i wasn't informed at all from a
business perspective on how to run my
finances and you weren't accountant and
worked in a bank but i guess like just
connecting that to the day-to-day and
that's the thing about like say the
education system i can do the corporate
finance course and still get a
module and get a 2-1 in my exams and
then work at bank of america merrill
lynch and work at all these like big
firms but they're not teaching me how to
live my life as an individual and how to
manage my finances as an individual and
actually in the bank
so many people who work there are in
debt like they were like i used to see
people who they're using their credit
cards they were struggling financially
and they were on high salaries but
they're living beyond their means so as
soon as they made money
like they were spending more than they
had like it was crazy so even in that
industry i think they were worse off
because they felt like they had to keep
up with everybody else is that something
that you've kind of struggled with the
whole keeping up with the joneses type
thing because because people talk about
it in films and books and stuff
but i guess i i don't like i think i
think of all my friends i know one guy
who
just freaking loves spending 600 quid on
a pair of shoes just to flash it at a
club and then never wear it again
but everyone else seems to be fairly
like like it's it seems like it seems to
me at least from the people that i know
that people have realized that keeping
up with the jones is a bad thing and so
then
just i think realizing that sort of
helps people not do it in a way but yeah
yeah
i think it depends on
your circle so my friends are not like
that my friends are really normal my
industry is about the spend the glamour
the designer the have you got the
cartier have you got the chanel bag have
you got the the outfits and the look so
for me i felt like i had to keep up like
i needed the next palette i needed the
next outfit or i needed to look amazing
at the next event so
i definitely overspent many many years
um trying to keep up with just the image
of of being an influencer because we're
we're influencing others and there's an
aspect of being aspirational that was
really important for us hmm
okay i guess the analogy there is
when you're a tech youtuber you need to
have the best desk set up yeah and you
will splash out like thousands on a
computer monitor you don't need because
it will make your desk setup look nicer
because it's somewhat aspirational to
people be like i've got cool desk setup
but i think you can kind of forgive that
because it's like that's your job right
you're playing the game in your job yeah
so do you
do people who are not professional
influencers who need to play the game
for their job do you find that they also
also fall into those similar traps so
yes and no so actually i recognize that
the amount i spend on clothing and bags
jewelry like is
is is maybe in a hundred thousand a year
right bloody which is insane right but
that is part of my job right so so
everybody else might be like what then
yeah tax deductibility
yeah whereas it is like i can expect the
expense most of them
um and maybe let's say 70 000 a year or
something like that so that is a lot
right but that's the nature of my job
but the thing that started to scare me
as and started to bother me was knowing
that there are other people who are
watching me
who
who it isn't their job but i might be
influencing them in that way so that's
why i had to come and bring my finance
knowledge to say yes i like a chanel bag
um i might buy four a year don't buy
four a year
save and buy one a year okay and this is
how to do it yeah so for me it was
really important to bring that balance
because we could look like
life is peachy and spending money all
the time but this is our job um and i
didn't want to encourage people to do
that as much okay so i guess that's how
you bet like yeah how do you balance
that i want to buy fortunate bags a year
with i'm encouraging people to live
frugally and
i don't want to get a housekeeper
because it might be expensive but i'm
buying four bags a year kind of like how
do you how do you balance those
different things
uh
i don't know i feel like i'd be called
out but the reality is that i'm still
trying to work on that like yeah because
i think everybody has two sides some of
us want to save more but some of us not
like nice things so i've i've accepted
that's what who i am and and what i'm
about but everything to me is also about
balance like um if i'm gonna buy the
four chanel bags maybe it won't before
maybe it'll be two and maybe i'll make
sure i've um saved and invested um this
amount first and then i'll buy the
chanel bag and that's how i advise
anyone who follows me and i used to do a
you know the a content format i used to
do was called haul videos oh yeah haul
videos is you showing all the stuff and
i had a series which was called i spent
that series probably did about 30 to 40
million views right and it was me
spending every week thousands of pounds
on
on fast fashion and people loved it
three million views four million views a
video but i physically couldn't do those
videos anymore i felt
sick because i was like i'm just i'm
part of the problem i had to stop so i
think that i've got a healthy balance
now how did you become so comfortable
talking openly about money slash why do
we not feel comfortable talking about it
do you reckon i don't know if i am that
comfortable talking about it i talk
about it because i think it's important
and necessary like i still feel a bit
icky sharing
certain numbers but i know how
beneficial it is when i do
um and so i think i allow the fact that
i know this is helpful um to override
the fact that i feel uncomfortable and i
i've shared this story a hundred times
but as an influencer i didn't know what
my value was i didn't know how much i
should pay i didn't know how much i
should be making until i one
accidentally stumbled across an assumed
rate of pay and two
someone told me how much they were
making on a monthly basis and it blew my
mind and i was like i don't even make a
tenth of that and she was maybe say
double my size and was making
10 times my amount and that was enough
for me to make a decision to say well
i'm going to at least try and reach half
and i did that in like a month and then
i then eventually
made that amount and surpassed that but
that figure was pivotal to changing my
mindset so i feel like if i can provide
people insight into what's possible then
i can help them and that's important to
me yeah i think that's probably similar
similar for me um
there's a level of
yeah a level of discomfort i am with
like sharing numbers i i think when the
numbers are small mm-hmm it's nice and
it's nice to share them oh i made i made
a few thousand for my business this year
and the numbers start to become
ridiculous at that point you're like
okay this is completely unattainable for
most people yes is the reason is the
only reason i'm doing this to flex and
like how much like you know even if i
can convince myself that the reason i'm
sharing these numbers is because it
helps people because it does mm-hmm how
much of like
how much of the actual reason behind why
i'm doing this is to ultimately flex
yeah
that's that's such a good point so even
me i don't share all my numbers because
i sometimes think that all my numbers
could be quite scary um to people so i
think as a creator our job is also about
relatability as well so i even did a
challenge where i opened up a small
online business
and um
and i didn't promote it and i didn't
market it and i didn't tell people that
it was my brand or anything and i did a
video on how i made say 8 000 a month
from this small business that i didn't
market so i was trying to just show
people that
eight thousand for an influencer
business is very small in the scheme of
things well for an everyday person
that's a lot of money so i actively did
that in that way so i could show people
how it's possible to create something
small
without using brand or name or anything
like that and build it from the ground
up and then i started getting stories
from people who had done the same thing
so i feel like
bringing the numbers in a way that's
understandable is important the big
numbers let's not let's not stress
people out yeah
how i made 10 million this year that's
your next video or something it's like
um
yeah
yeah yeah um this was so we were working
with this youtube growth coach guy um
his insight was like really helpful like
we we we were sort of brainstorming
title ideas for a video
um and
you know there was there was there was
some like numbers we were playing around
with we were like you know should we
make this how i make a hundred thousand
dollars a month from of off off the back
of this business or something like that
and he was like no no make it how you
make a thousand dollars a month of the
background
because that's like infinitely more
relatable to people if they see a
hundred thousand a month they can just
assume it's not for them and that's
completely impossible which is kind of
true yeah um but a thousand dollars a
month feels more manageable for example
100 a week or even 100 a day like those
sorts of more manageable numbers rather
than getting into the tens of thousands
or the hundred thousand exactly kind of
thing um what was the like let's say
someone is listening to this they're
like you know mid early to mid 20s
they've got a job and they want to do a
business on the side
to make that 8 000 a month or whatever
to supplement their income
what would how how would you approach
that like do you have a method a system
process
so i mean i would tell people to use the
skills that they currently have
knowledge they currently have tools that
they currently have so if you know
something so say someone i know
who's really good at excel will just
either help people build excel templates
or sell excel templates like this is
something you can already do that's
where i would start off and then looking
at scaling that um or pricing it higher
that's what i would tell most people to
do i wouldn't tell them to go and invest
in a product
um and spend loads of on inventory
without testing a model first because i
think that's really expensive
and actually hard to like make happen
but i'd just say use what you've got
like if you've got a spare room rent
that out why you would have a spare room
i don't know but something like that or
if you like animals why don't you start
pet sitting or something or dog walking
so loads of dog walkers make like a ton
of money because they like dog walk 10
10 dollars for like 50 pounds a day they
can make like 500 pounds a day is that
is that the right math yeah yeah there
we go
they can do that right and even for
instance i'm working with a cake
decorator and someone who does balloons
in decor and like you know i'm paying
her 500 pounds and it's it's something i
can't do but she's really good at she
loves it um so there's ways that people
can make money from things that they
they are good at doing already yeah
yeah it's like that venn diagram of the
the things that you're good at the
things that you like and the things that
there is a market for exactly and i
remember when
you know my
uh
in you know i i like to think of it as
my origin story when i was 18 years old
got scammed out of my life savings when
buying a macbook off of gumtree um and i
was like right i need to make this
thousand pounds back because i'd saved
up for like years and years to get to
that point and i was like all right
what's the list of things i'm good at
and the things i like doing and on that
list was teaching on that list of was
like making websites and on that list
was um i did reasonably well in med
school entrance exams to gain
that was like cool what if i combine
teaching with the med school entrance
exam so i teach people how to get into
med school and then i make a website for
it that markets at nationally and that
was the thing that made my business
successful uh
and
you know
i
just think a lot i think a lot of people
are like hey i'm gonna learn day trading
completely from scratch and then i'm
going to make a load of money because i
found some course that does it it's like
it's really hard yeah to
compete in a market where you are not
already good at the thing exactly so
step one is to get good at something and
if you're already good at something then
find a way to make money off the back of
that if you can exactly if not it's
you're fighting a losing battle or you
recognize that it's not going to be fast
so if you want to be a day trader you're
going to spend three years or two years
dedicated to learning it entirely fine
but you might be broke and lose loads of
money in during that period of time but
you can get good in like three years
right 10 000 hours and all that jazz so
if you're willing to put the work in to
get it good at something that's
lucrative fine go ahead and do it but i
think most people have got abilities
within themselves now to do something
yeah
what about the whole um people who
decide they want to become a creator
because it makes money and they see
people like you and me being open about
some of some of our numbers they're like
oh i want a slice of that pie it's not
scalable or sustainable if you don't
want to do it so i
when i started there was no money in it
so when i there was i did it these
videos for three years without making a
penny i didn't know you could make any
money in it i was just doing it every
single weekend after exams after
interning
like
every saturday i would just come and
make videos because i loved doing it um
and it i didn't see it as a business at
all i do think if you wanted to come in
strategically i'm not mad at that like
if you're strategic and you're like i'm
gonna make money as a creator and this
and this and this and this is what i'm
gonna do
fine execute your plan and see what
happens um yeah i think it's like uh
it's the way we teach this in our on our
course is sort of this there's kind of
two approaches to being being like a
youtuber for example
there's uh the archaeologist there's the
architect so an archaeologist is like
cool this looks good i'm gonna make a
video a few videos here and then okay
didn't really enjoy that let's find
another one make a few videos there and
eventually they'll stumble on something
that's like oh i enjoy this people are
getting it's getting views and life is
good
and that seems to be how most youtubers
start off just making videos here and
there until they stumble on their niche
uh
and that's probably still what i'd
recommend for complete beginners who
don't know how to make videos because it
takes a while to get good actually
making videos but if you are a already
good at making videos or b you just want
to treat it like a business from day one
then approaching it more like an
architect is potentially a strategy
where you analyze the market you build
out your plan and then
once you've got a clear idea of what
your plan is then you execute on it
right um and so there's been quite a few
channels that have decided to
for example create content in the
finance space where the cpms are
ridiculous yeah uh because they're like
oh there's a clear business here where
you make content about books you need
about 50 times the amount of views to
get the same amount of money so like i
don't just make one finance video rather
than yeah you're worth the books videos
yeah to get the same amount of money and
it becomes like a business decision at
that point yeah but that's like does
that inspire you like that so i did i
did i have a whole channel that grew to
half a million in like a year
on finance stuff and i love it but like
i'm bored of talking about finance now
like i love it and there's other stuff i
want to do around it but the way in
which i've i did it i feel like i've
taught and shared everything that i have
within myself right now about finance
i'm okay to like cool down on that
although i have a new series coming um
that i wanted to talk about a few things
that i thought would be super valuable
for people but again my approach is
different yeah i'm i'm a
not an architect i'm a archaeologist
archaeologist
who wants to have architects yeah
tendencies
it sounds like from the from the
conversations we've been having like
you're more creator first
and sort of
you're more of a creative who's then
building a business around that
whereas i feel like
i approach things as more of like an
entrepreneur where then the creator
element is just sort of a sprinkle into
that um i'm trying to get there but
again i like the idea of like doing it
from how i feel and what my heart says
because i think that's actually better
in the long run
or i feel more satisfaction absolutely
yeah definitely that way yeah where
someone else you know may feel like the
fact that i've executed in my plan they
feel better from executing their plan
which might be more of you yeah yeah
potentially but i find for me as well
like when i go too much into the into
businessman territory it stops becoming
fun okay and then i'm like okay let's
like claw it back a little bit and
finding some kind of middle way of like
creator an entrepreneur and finding a
way for the two to me in the middle
so retaining like the artsy side of
being a creator with the data driven
sciencey plan quarterly planning side of
being an entrepreneur for example i need
probably more of that
i'm gonna get there nice what does your
business look like at the moment like
what are the what is the patricia
portfolio look like portfolio look like
okay so maybe i break it down so
i do you mean like as an individual or
personally as well at both okay so
i have i am an influencer in terms of i
talk about products and i work with
brands a lot um so most of my memory in
you comes from like brand partnerships
brand deals and working with them
and then i also have the break the break
is actually revenue well revenue
generating from
the digital products so we do sell
digital products and guides and we have
a career course coming out as well and
then um
i then have my investment
business as well so we've invested into
a couple of companies that's not revenue
generating just yet but that's like a
long-term plan as well as then the
properties that i've invested into and
then the next arm is really the kind of
product arm that i'm going down which is
about bringing physical products to life
with my partners
so
the break is sort of youtube channel
website generating content mostly
through ads and uh digital products
digital and we had a physical product so
we have a plan on our plan and we've
done it two years in a row it's been
really popular and but i'm not doing
planners again yeah
why not
labor intensive timelines
china lower margins italy
shipping ports weight all these stuff
that
you don't want to deal with
yeah we don't want to deal with it
there's other ways that we can provide
value that doesn't give us that much
aggro and your and your brand deals it's
a i noticed that you
don't publish on youtube that regularly
anymore compared to what you're used to
is that mostly on instagram these days
or like what is what does it look like
exactly it's mainly on um instagram now
in terms and i i still get youtube deals
i think
i think i only post when i have a
youtube deal which is so bad
um but um i get deals on youtube and i
still get deals on instagram but
instagram's probably bigger now okay and
what's the how do you find how do you
strike the balance between
uh
promoting a brand deal versus actually
creating content that feels authentic to
you that grows your audience
or
are they sort of tangled up together
they're kind of tangled up just together
because i only work on brand deals with
products and services that i love that i
know my audience will want to see and
know and use anyway
and that also includes like affiliate
linking so the good thing about
my job as an influence is that our job
is always to tell people about products
and always to tell people about things
we like and use so i still get to do
that and then i get paid to do that so
it's not like i talk about other things
and then i'm like use this product yeah
like was me working with say estee
lauder or lancome or
um l'oreal these are brands and products
i use all the time so if they launch
something new i'm like oh my god this is
something new i'm trying it out i'm
showing them how i try it out and i'll
give my opinion but sometimes it's not
even about my opinion it's just me
showing how the products used and i
would have used it and bought it anyway
so
nice the balance is
there isn't really one it's just i keep
creating what i was creating anyway oh
okay
yeah that makes a lot of sense i guess
yeah the way i think of brand deals like
and and i don't know if this is
the right way to think of them so i'd
love to get your take on this it's like
kind of putting something out there that
gives value to the audience for free
is like uh
almost like sort of adding money to the
goodwill account and anytime i do a
brand deal or try and sell something
it's withdrawing money from the goodwill
account and there needs to be this
balance between depositing into the
account and withdrawing from it but i
don't know if this is actually true i'm
just kind of pushing myself maybe that's
the opposite way of you thinking about
it so when i tell my audience about a
new product
i'm adding into the goodwill account
because this is something they may want
to try use or even know about so like
i'm giving them something that they
weren't aware of so i use a lot of
affiliate links i know that people want
to buy the dress or they want to buy the
makeup they want to buy it they're
purchasing it they wanted it so imagine
if i so i recently worked to say
elizabeth arden
and i gave i gave them a free gift with
it or so when they make a purchase they
get
a free product so many people bought it
because they've been wanting to try it
out so i've just told them about
something that they didn't know but they
want so i don't see it like yeah oh
interesting so it's like the mindset of
like in a way promoting and selling is
not an evil thing it's actually doing
the audience a service by telling them
about a thing that they might want yeah
and again my industry has always been
about showing product so i'm just
showing product that they want to know
like there are people who watch qvc for
fun
right so i would say that my audience
are the kind of people who would love
qvc i always say i'm an infomercial
queen i love watching ads to decide what
i might want to buy next like i'm that
kind of person and i think the people
who follow me like want to know stuff oh
okay and then like so with the with the
property portfolio are you are you open
to talking about that yeah yeah how did
that develop over time when did you get
started um so uh so funny enough my mom
actually
owned property so she's an immigrant but
she bought her like first council house
um and then she bought like five to six
properties in total around the uk
herself and so when i was like 18 i was
helping her do that even when i was at
uni i helped her like with tenancy
agreements and um like cleaning and all
that kind of jazz so i've always been
into property and i thought i hated i
thought i hated property management but
then when i started to get revenue and
had some extra and i was like well what
should i do with this the the first
thing i thought was you know what let me
get into the property market and so um
i bought oh the first place we actually
bought was buying my own house from me
um
we're using the company money to buy a
house that we already owned and so
the company
now owns my old house so that we could
get the money to buy a new house and
then
that was rented out and that was that's
been really cool and that's fun and then
um
the next property was because my sister
was looking for her
her house and then the guy was like well
there's a flat upstairs you might want
to look at it costs a bit more but you
might like it and we're like oh this is
really cool so we bought that flat and
then
we like we're looking at some auction
properties and we bought one without
seeing it and then we bought it was oh
we love this and then we bought that
property and then a few others and then
oh well it just kind of cascaded from
there okay
so it's like you have a property
investment company that buys the
properties and then the rent goes into
that yes so we have an investment
company specifically for property nice
yeah that's really cool i've started
dabbling with that like in the last few
months myself okay and it's quite fun
it's cool i don't do a lot of it i'm not
gonna lie my husband is there he loves
the property stuff because he goes to
the house oh okay he fixed stuff and he
like sees the electrician or he'll be
like there with his like tool belt on
i've just got something to go sort out
so he loves that kind of stuff so he's
living his dream i'm like yeah you do it
whatever you like and yeah i think
that's uh again speaking going back to
that autonomy thing we were talking
about um it seems like a lot of
people who make money on the internet
then are very keen to diversify away
from internet based revenue streams into
something bricks and mortar z like
property because it's like you make
money off of youtube or whatever and you
know that you've got a few years in the
limelight to really make hay while the
sun shines and you want to try to funnel
that into more like long-term
investments
i think it's a smart thing to do i think
it's what anybody with money does so i
have friends who are not in um
the world that we're in um they have
property as well like my friend my one
of my friends has a coffee shop as well
so he's invested into like hardcore
brick and mortar businesses um so it's i
think it's just smart money to do that
kind of thing
does your so you're fairly open to
talking about this does your audience
not like hate you for being a landlord
or are they just fairly children my
audience do not hate me for being a
landlord because i think people have
seen my journey they know where i've
come from they've no see me living in my
mom's house in one room they know that i
didn't have like i did not grow up with
a silver spoon or i've not had to do
anything like crazy to make to generate
revenue i've just continued to provide
value and entertainment and enjoyment
and that's how i've generated revenue
however i understand that some people
are kind of against you know people who
have resources but bearing in mind i
grew up in cancer property and i've had
i lived in property with bad landlords
and you know the government being my
landlord so for me i was like if i have
this opportunity i'm going to make sure
i'm going to be a better version of a
landlord so i don't increase rents so at
least i know my tenants are happy this
is my little way of like helping because
the houses that we bought were in
complete disrepair that nobody wanted
like the government was selling off
houses and like okay fine buy that one
that no one no one wants it and i can
afford it i'll buy it
and someone's in there
um i guess
final question i want to ask on the
money front and then i want to shift the
gear to like identity it's like
just just to sign first that
um do you feel like you have enough
money or do you feel like you need to
make more and then at some point you
will have enough oh yeah i don't feel
like i have enough money
yeah that's a fact
so i
need more
um i'd like more for different things so
when i think about how long life is
and then i think about like my revenue
generating years i recognize that
there's probably more i need um for the
fact that i have children and i want
them to go to school and then there are
other things i'm going to do for other
people and like i want to be able to buy
someone a house and be like oh that's
fine like and then buy my mom's house
and then do this for someone who needs
it so i know that i'm nowhere near that
figure that i want to be at to do the
things that i want to do okay have you
got a number in mind
or is it just sort of more than 100
million oh okay yeah
it's a billion
is it ever increasing number i bet um
no i don't have a specific figure okay
yeah this is something that i think
about a lot because again coming back to
that stuff we were talking about around
doing things for the passion versus
doing things for the money
and something i often think about is
like
uh what like if i
what's the difference between the way
i'm spending my time right now versus
the way i would spend my time if i had
100 million in the bank oh okay and like
so and therefore that those two
different scenarios illustrate what are
the things i'm doing for money rather
than for fun
and so i think even if i had 100 million
in the bank i would still make youtube
videos and i would still do podcasts
because it's cool talking to people but
i probably wouldn't do courses because
courses are specifically a revenue
generating thing and i just chuck them
online for free
and so for me it's like well then
therefore the primary reason i'm doing
courses is because it makes money which
we then need to sustain the business but
either way it's doing it for the money
rather than for the joy yeah and so i i
often feel like what's what's that
balance between like do i actually have
enough i mean you know with investments
and stuff
i could probably comfortably get 40k a
year and if i need to i can always just
do freelance stuff yeah so then why am i
doing all this other thing like how do
you think about that yeah
um that's a really good point i don't
know if i do think about that um
i mean i do feel like i could live
comfortably
and
i feel like i just know that there's
other stuff i need to do so until i'm
there i
i
will continue to work towards it but now
i'm also in the position that i
recognize creation is my main driver as
i've discussed previously and if the
money comes the money comes and if it
doesn't it doesn't like i'm i'm not
going to kill myself over that because
again i've recognized that money isn't a
main motivator for me as well so um i
think i'm satisfied but i think i'd
always want more yeah fair
who doesn't want more who doesn't want a
bit more money who doesn't want to
look a bit better and be a bit younger
and grow a bit more so yeah yeah so you
talking some of the finance education
stuff around kind of living frugally um
you know as you probably know there's
this this concept in the personal
finance world uh lifestyle inflation yes
and how as you make more money your you
end up spending more money and you know
like you said a lot of your colleagues
at the bank would make having high
salaries but
were
living beyond their means
do you try and combat lifestyle
inflation or like how do you
how do you
feel about that side of things i think
i'm actually really good like
in terms of from my earnings and to how
much i spend i am
my percentage is really good i don't
spend like to the max i save quite a lot
and i think that is again because i've
learned to be frugal again it's all
relative because i still buy my chanel
but you know i could buy more than that
you know if i wanted to i
don't want to but like i have friends
who have like aston martins and like
bentleys and like this kind of stuff in
my industry and i'm like oh no way i
could never do that because in my mind
it just feels excessive um but for them
it might be the right thing to do i just
wouldn't do that so i i recognize
lifestyle inflation and i've avoided it
um and i'm i'm more about investing for
the long run
nice
um i want to change gears a bit too
talking about identity so
you um i think a few a few minutes ago
when we were talking when i asked you
about your portfolio you said well i'm
an influencer therefore i work with
brands et cetera et cetera how do you
think of your own identity that's a good
question
this is a really good question that i'm
still trying to define and actually
redefine so
for the last 10 years i've been uh maybe
i should say online content creator
because it's not just about influencing
i've been educating i've been
entertaining i've been creating content
and i also work with brands so i've been
an online content creator for the last
10 years but and that's been my identity
which is putting myself out there in a
way that most people don't put
themselves out there i realize i'm a
weirdo for what i put out there it's
crazy that i do this but i do whereas i
know that like for the next 10 years i
know that i want to you know also wear
other hats and i'm also a mom and i'm
also a wife and i'm also an entrepreneur
and i also run a brand in businesses so
i think i want to lean more into those
as an identity um moving forward
[Music]
the identity of personality as well i'm
a personality yeah but i feel like
everyone's a personality so
i don't know what that means okay
yeah i kind of find when i find myself
struggling with this when like it's it's
very easy to have a very legible
identity as being a doctor never ever
knows what that means oh yeah exactly
and then you leave that behind you're
like oh am i you know i guess i guess
i'm an influencer now what what and then
there's a prestige associated with it
like you know i worked in banking i was
a banker you know or i'm a consultant
it's like i'm an online content creator
yeah
like i take photos like exactly like you
know i'm a doctor that i make videos
on the internet yeah that's it's a weird
thing like because it's still valuable
like there is this thing of people even
in the industry they want to label you
like even i work with certain management
companies like well you're not a model
you're not an author you're not at this
so they like to put people in specific
boxes i'm like definitely not a model
and i'm definitely not well i am an
author because i published a book but i
don't call myself an author
but maybe i should
i don't know we could all wear different
hats and have different titles yeah yeah
one one piece of advice i got from one
of my author friends was uh
don't worry about the noun think about
the verb so it's not
i am a doctor i am a youtuber i am a
writer it's like
i spend my time
teaching medicine i spend some of my
time making videos i spend some of my
time right doing writing and thinking in
those terms means that we're less
it's less like boxy because when is boxy
in a way there's something exclusive
about that oh i'm an author that's my
primary thing okay why do you think like
what do you actually do oh well i look
after the kids i write books
occasionally i watch a bunch of tv and i
record podcasts there's something about
that that feels to me more of like a can
i try and internally shift my identity
into the things that i do uh preferably
not even that preferably actually my
identity is who i am rather than what i
do but until we get to that point of
enlightenment yeah my identity is you
know the
the verb that i'm doing rather than the
noun yeah that corresponds to i think
that's great for us and as an individual
but i don't know if other people on the
outside like accept that yeah but it's
that when you're talking to the
companies and yeah marketeers are like
well you know we can't put that in the
trap line yeah exactly so
yeah yeah there's a friend of mine uh
paul paul millard wrote this book oh the
populist path which i always find myself
plugging in these podcasts because it's
like um basically how you find figure
out what what you want to do in life and
sort of reimagining our relationships
careers and work and stuff and so he
used to be a high-paying management
consultant in like new york and then he
quit his job and became freelance and
then he kind of jokes that people would
ask him oh so what do you do and he'd be
like oh you know i you know i go for
walks in the park and i read some books
and you know i listen to a podcast
occasionally and he would just people
would just be like wait a minute what
like
that that's not an acceptable answer to
what do you do like they want a job
title
rather than what do you actually spend
your time doing yeah you seem to be very
comfortable being authentic and being
vulnerable and like
giving a lot of yourself to the internet
and have done for the last 12 years how
did you get comfortable doing that were
you always that way
like
yeah
so actually i don't know if i am that
comfortable with it
i think i'm a natural over-sharer okay
i'm a natural like people-pleaser okay
as well and when i put myself out there
there was no one watching so i got so
comfortable with putting myself out
there in this way like when i first
started creating youtube wasn't the
thing that it is today so it was so easy
to naturally just be yourself
and i just continued to do that because
now that's what i've developed um but it
is hard but i've recognized the power of
me sharing my truth um and just being
authentically me and how much that
impacts others um and i like and i've
liked doing it but there's a part of me
that is ready now to like hold back a
little bit more and share
in a way that's a bit more channeled and
productive
productive as in like strategic for your
wider business goals exactly strategic i
don't need to share with you what i had
for breakfast yeah you know my bowel
movements yeah i've done that i've not
done that but like
like you know it's a lot like
there's no need for it like and also
there's like this thing of like
authenticity for the sake of like
authenticity's sake it's like almost
like pretend authenticity which you see
a lot of people doing and it's not real
it's very cringe to me like i'm so
authentic no you're not it's an act
you're just over sharing for the sake of
it but um i'm trying to like just kind
of
hone back a bit oh interesting yeah so
and so um i feel like a lot of people
are in the other way around where
they're like oh i feel really shy about
putting myself out there online i know
it's probably better if i go a little
bit more in terms of being comfortable
with kind of being authentic on the
internet do you have any advice for
those people that are struggling with
authenticity or
displaying
or being comfortable with putting
themselves out there for example
well i understand why someone would feel
uncomfortable putting themselves out
there and i think you are in control of
what you put out there but you can't
control how people are going to react to
it so there's an element of caution that
you do have to
exercise but it's important for you to
put your own boundaries like around that
like okay i want to put myself out there
but i don't want to show my kids i'm
going to put myself out there but i'm
not going to share this side of things
that you can determine the factors of
how you want to do that yeah and for me
my over sharing i've you know for now
i'm just like um i'll share in a more
structured manner so it might be a sit
down video where i explain something and
i've done that in the past so like i
shared my birth stories and that's
that's been watched by more than two
million people and it was it was me
definitely sharing quite a dramatic
moment but it was structured oh it
wasn't real time vlogging live streaming
i mean there's some clips there there's
a bit like oh and there's you know i've
actually had real-time clips of when i
gave birth to my first daughter and i
said you know what we're not putting
this out yeah we just kept the sound
effect
it's a lot but i wouldn't do that now
that was too much that was too much why
do you know it wasn't too much because
people loved it yeah like and people and
i loved it because i watched so many
women give birth that's how i knew how
to what was going to happen so like i
felt like i had to give back but now i'm
like i can't believe i put that out
there
but because it's cringe or like what
just because it's a lot i can't even
watch the video oh okay like because i'm
like it's emotional it's cringy it's
like ah
lots of stuff
how did having kids change your online
[Music]
stuff if at all
my ability to create as much as fast was
reduced
um but i didn't change what i put out
there because i i'm not really the most
like mummy i'm not a mummy blogger i
don't make content about my children
yeah my children are in my content but i
don't make it about them at all um but
before i could like film at three
o'clock in the morning if i wanted to i
could film any time of day but i can't
do that now with kids like that they've
got to be
you know certain things has to be done
in the morning they've got to be picked
up after school i've got to be around as
a parent and present so i can't you know
make as much on the fly content as i
used to okay
and did you i'm bound by time yeah
did you find that you
because one thing one thing i've heard
from a lot of like startup founders
before and after kids is like before
kids it's like
the the the main thing in my life is my
work and therefore i'm hustling at all
hours a day because it's really fun and
after kids it's like
i still enjoy the work and i still enjoy
hustling but actually there's i get a
lot of joy of spending time with the
kids now and so in a way the focus gets
split did you find that happen for you
or like how how do i i guess i'm what
i'm asking is how do you balance
family life versus there's definitely a
split of focus and i think i'm going to
be completely transparent i have the
desire to spend way more time working
like i have i want to do more work but i
recognize that i can't i love being with
my children and stuff so i have to
sacrifice some of the work stuff that i
love doing because i want to be a really
present and valuable parent so sometimes
it feels like a bit of a sacrifice but
in the same breath like i'm so joyful
and happy when i'm with my children that
it doesn't feel it doesn't feel like a
bad thing and also that when i then
dedicate loads of time to work i'm like
oh my god i just want to be at home with
my kids so
i want both
basically you just find a way to make it
work exactly
and you have to give a little and take a
little and i know that my time is
restrained and that's what it is do you
worry about like the longevity of the
career in an industry that's focused so
much on looking young and looking young
forever kind of stuff not for me no
because i again i've i think it's very
important to develop other skill sets
and i look up to
um
women who
have had long term careers and it isn't
just because they look good like there's
you have to have something else so i
pride myself in like in my industry i'm
not the like the best looking girl in
terms of like i know the girls who are
the hot girls right who look amazing but
they've not got much to say about them
so i've seen hot girls come and go and
new hot girls come in and replace them
but those who have personality and
something about them are the ones who
usually have like more
to say or they have more sticking power
so that's why i see myself i want to be
like 75 and witty with great hair
and fake boobs
nice
i feel like that's a great place to end
the conversation thank you very much
patricia um any anything you'd like to
plug any by any ask for the audience
anything like that but nothing to plug
right now oh that's that's coming later
okay let's see yeah we'll put links down
follow me on instagram yep link to all
of the stuff down below and we'll we'll
be the first to know when when new stuff
comes out perfect thanks very much thank
you all right so that's it for this
week's episode of deep dive thank you so
much for watching or listening all the
links and resources that we mentioned in
the podcast are going to be linked down
in the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the itunes
store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full hd or 4k on
youtube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye